Hey traders, it's Mike from Orderflows
here and I have a huge announcement
about the major upgrade that we've made
on the Orderflows Delta Scalper. Now,
you know, if you follow me for any
period of time, you know I'm a big order
flow advocate. And you know why order
flow matters so much is because
orderflow analysis is the best way to
see the real forces that move the
market, the aggressive buyers and
aggressive sellers in real time. And
order flow delta provides an immediate
accurate reading of who is in control,
the buyers or the sellers. And it's
based off of what's happening right now,
not what happened minutes ago or hours
ago. So unlike lagging indicators
like MACD or RSI, orderflow delta reacts
to real market behavior as it unfolds.
So if you want to capture truly
highquality trades, you need to see how
the market participants are trading in
real time. Now, orderflow delta as
opposed to options delta, right? Don't
get the two uh mixed up, right? Or
options delta is completely different
than the orderflow delta. Orderflow
delta is the difference between the
volume traded at the bid and volume
traded at the offer. It measures the
strength of the aggressive traders in
the market. You know, the ones who move
price. And your goal as a trader is to
buy when buyers are strong and sell when
sellers dominate. So, most losing
traders ignore realtime strength and
weakness. Don't be one of them. The
Delta Scalper lets you harness this
powerful signal easily. Even if you
aren't familiar with order flow charts,
if you're familiar with order flow
charts, like a volume footprint chart,
this is what it would look like, right?
You'll you'll see signals from the Delta
Scalper appearing on your footprint
chart. Now, the beauty of it is the
Delta Scalper reads the information from
a footprint chart that would normally be
plotted on a footprint chart, but plots
it on a normal candlestick chart for
you. So if you're using already a
candlestick chart, you can use the
Orderflow Delta Scalper with it. So the
Delta Scalper brings professional
orderflow analysis to every trader, even
if you use only standard bar or
candlestick charts. This innovative tool
automates the complex work of
interpreting the delta from order flow
footprint charts. So you're going to get
powerful real-time buy and sell signals
without guessing or analyzing endless
barby charts. No more reading the tea
leaves, so to speak, or second guessing
what the market is doing because Delta
Scalper gives you a high conviction
setups easily, even if you aren't
familiar with orderflow charts, okay?
And like I said, you know, you're going
to get the buy signals plotted on your
chart, whether it's a footprint chart or
a bar or candlestick chart, right? And
it just makes understanding what's
taking place in the order flow a lot
easier, right? You don't have to sit
there and analyze, okay, what does this
delta mean? Uh what or what does this
one mean? What does this one mean? The
Delta Scalper does that for you. Now,
one of the functions that we've added
recently to or most recently to the
Delta Scalper is the PC movement
feature. PC, which is the point of
control. Point of control in order flow
um is is taken from market profile,
volume profile. It's the price level
with the most volume, right? So in
volume profile, market profile, it's the
price level for the day with the most
volume in in order flow. We look at it
on a barby bar basis. So
in that bar, whether it's a one minute
bar, so in that one minute period, your
PC is the price level with the most
volume. If you're looking at a
rangebased chart, um in that bar, that's
the price level. Say you're on a 10
range chart. In that one bar on your 10
range chart, the price level with the
most volume is the point of control. And
what that signals right is volume
acceptance. So you can see when the PC
shifts higher as prices rise, the market
is embracing higher prices. That
indicates true conviction is present.
You're going to see market rejection
alerts. You're going to spot falling PC
as price drops. You know, traders won't
buy at higher levels. This is genuine
selling pressure appearing in the
market. And you can analyze convictions.
You can watch shifts bar to bar to catch
new trends and see which moves have fuel
behind them and it helps you pick up uh
reversals because when price moves one
way but PC moves the opposite, you're
going to suspect a possible reversal
taking place and you catch them early.
And so, you know, the PC movement
feature really covers a lot of ground in
what's taking place in the market. And
one of the ways that um it is very
useful is getting you out of bad trades,
right? A market that's going sideways
isn't really a great trading market. So
you can see, right, this is a signal
that was generated with Delta Scalper,
right? And this market just continue to
go sideways. But when you add the PC
movement
as a sort of a filter
in the signal,
you don't get the buy signal because
it's it's picking up that the PC there's
no shift in volume taking place, right?
And and that's the beauty of it, right?
If you can eliminate some of the trades
that are, you know, sort of borderline,
right? All the conditions are met, but
now that we've taken it to a second uh
or not a second level, but a higher
level, right? Meaning, okay, now we want
to make sure that this market is either
going to be reversing or is breaking out
or has conviction to it as opposed to
maybe, you know, a big order because
sometimes, um, a big order can cause,
you know, delta to jump, right? And if
you got a big jump in delta all of a
sudden, it could mean something. But if
it means if it's coming in in the middle
of sideways activity, right, where
traders are happy to transact,
that's where you expect the big orders
to come. So we we've sort of been able
to identify those bars where we're not
getting that movement that's required um
for a move to happen.
Last year, we added the multi-time frame
analysis in the Delta Scalper. What that
does is it allows you to overlay
different time frame Delta Scalper
signals onto any chart for a richer
context. So, for example, you can see
signals from a five-minute chart while
trading the one minute chart for added
clarity and confidence. So, you can be
able to capture the bigger picture of
supply and demand shifts and short-term
trading opportunities. And this feature
is a real breakthrough for scalpers and
intraday traders working with multiple
time frames. So this is a one minute
chart on E- minis. And this is just the
normal delta scalper signals. All right,
on the one minute chart and for some
traders, you know, this is fine. This is
good enough. But I know some traders,
they like to look at higher time frames
and they're always wondering, okay,
what's taking place on a higher time
frame? So now you can add the signals
from a five minute. Say you you you like
the signals that are generated on a
fivem minute time frame in Delta
Scalper, you could put them onto your
one minute chart. Okay? And the beauty
is, you know, all if say you want to
have one minute, you know, say you trade
a one minute chart, you want to have
three minute signals, five minute
signal, maybe a 15-minute signal, you
could add each of those on there. All
you got to do is, you know, so you're
not confused is you just change the
colors of the actual signals, right? So
maybe um, you know, the one minute would
be the default blue and red. A 3 minute
might be green and um, you know, pink
and so on, right? You just change those
the colors schemes. Okay? But again, it
it helps traders that want to look at
sort of a higher time frame. um because
you know there people believe that on
higher time fra signals generated on
higher time frames can be stronger
especially on shorter term charts.
Last year we also added the momentum
feature. Okay, because price action
alone isn't enough. Momentum reflects
the strength and direction of a move.
Right? Because you know if trends happen
right when they start picking up
momentum and that's the beauty of the
momentum strength setting is it adds a
new dimension to every signal. So you're
confirming whether a move has real force
behind it and momentum aligns with order
flow. When both point in the same
direction you have the highest
probability setups. Now there's
different levels you could set for. I
mean you could disable the momentum
feature if you don't want to use it. You
could set it at weak average or strong.
I like to just sort of keep it average.
Making sure I have some momentum so that
my signals are aligned with the
direction of the market, but it's
adjustable for your trading style or
market speed. Now, here's an example.
Again, this is a E- mini. This is just,
you know, default settings of Delta
Scalper. You know, there's some good
signals, but there's a couple trades in
here, all right, that are a bit iffy.
You know, this one started to work and
then came out, would have stopped you
out. Same with this one. started to sell
off, came back up and stopped you out.
You know, imagine all these trades in
here and there's some good ones, right?
There's some really nice trades. What if
you can remove one or two bad trades
from your trading log per day? Meaning,
I'll say, you know, erase them, but not
take them, right? If if why, you know,
here's a trade you got stopped out on.
Here's a trade you got stopped out on.
What if you can have two less trades a
day that you're getting stopped out on?
you know, two less trades that you're
taking a loss on. That's what momentum
um this momentum setting does is it
removes this, you know, these two trades
that didn't have the momentum behind it.
Okay? So, that that's going to keep you
out of, you know, a few bad trades over
the course of a day. And imagine, right,
if if you're just removing one or two
bad trades per day, what does that mean
for you at the end of the week, at the
end of the month, end of the quarter,
and end of the year, right? your trading
um journal at the end of the year when
you go through it. You know, sometimes
you're like, "Oh man, if I didn't take
that one trade or these these couple of
trades could have made all the
difference in the world." That's the
beauty of the momentum setting is it's
going to keep you out of, you know,
potentially some of these trades that
are just uh not good trades to take.
Now,
one of the features that we have in the
Delta Scalper that we have in a lot of
our indicators is the trade entry
signal, which is a bad trade filter in a
sense, right? Not every signal is worth
taking, right? Because again, you know,
when you're looking at order flow,
sometimes, no matter what tool you're
using, a big order hits the market and
it sort of gets the market in a in a
flurry, right? Oh, there's a big order
coming in. Um, and especially with
delta, right, a big order is going to be
is going to affect the delta. But what
the trade entry signal does is it
confirms if there's actual follow
through because it's one thing to have a
big order hit the market, but what you
need is follow through, right? You need
subsequent trade in that direction of
the big order as opposed to someone just
get me out of the market. Um, so that's
what the trade enters signal does. It
prints only when subsequent bars show
continuation in your trades direction.
So, it's going to help filter out noise
and sideways markets. Very customizable.
You can set the how many ticks and bars
must confirm movement for a trade signal
to be valid. And this keeps you out of
many fake out trades, right? Where it
looks like it's going to go
and then it doesn't so that you can
focus on your energy on high conviction
trade setups. So, the Delta Scalper is
going to help improve your trading
because it's going to pinpoint low-risk,
highreward entry zones with clear visual
signals. It's going to let you use tight
stop losses, immediate feedback if
you're wrong, so you never hope and
hold, right? Ah, this trade is going to
come back. Well, if it reaches, you
know, if it immediately hits your your
stop level, you get out, right? And it's
and it draws on your chart where you
should be getting out. It's going to
show you where trends often start by
mapping real shifts in supply and
demand. It's going to highlight where
institutional traders are active. So,
you're not trading blind guessing,
especially if you're looking at a
candlestick chart, right? Candlestick
chart doesn't show volume. So, you don't
know when um you know, the big orders
are hitting the market and big orders
are driven by big traders. Most
importantly, it's going to take the
stress out of trading. So, you know, if
a trade is working fast and avoid doubt
that plagues many traders, right? It's
that second-guing that stresses the heck
out of traders.
Tra Delta Scalper solves
many of the biggest mistakes that
traders make, right? Many losing traders
ignore market strength and weakness and
rely on outdated, laggy indicators,
right? Following price alone isn't
following strength, right? You always
want to be buying strength and selling
weakness. Traders overtrade. They take
boredom trades and use wide stops that
destroy risk and reward. Right? If you
don't know where a trade should be
invalidated,
then it's not really a trade you should
be taking. If you have to set wide
stops,
it's probably not really worth the the
risk for you. Delta Scalper solves these
issues by objectively showing when the
real supply and demand shifts occur.
provides clarity and structure so you
only take the best trades and know when
to exit. Okay. Now, the Delta Scalper
works across all types of markets and
charts. It works on nearly every market,
indices, FX, commodities, and more. No
need for curve fitting. Now, of course,
you you're welcome to adjust it to your
market and your trading style, right?
Everyone has a different uh you know
risk parameters
that you know is going to adjust how
they view the market and trade the
market. Same settings which you can
adjust, same logic, reliable signals
applied to multiple markets seamlessly.
meaning you know like settings that I
use for
eurourcurrency, same one I use for
British pound, same for crude, um you
know and and gold, you know, I might
adjust maybe the momentum setting or the
PC movements. But in general, most of
the settings are are pretty set. I don't
need to to oh, in this market I use this
setting and another market I use a
completely different type of setting.
No, it's generally um you know, I don't
say one sizefits-all, but it's it's
pretty darn close to it.
So, who is the Delta Scalper for? Well,
it's for scalpers, right? I mean, the
term Delta Scalper, right? It's
literally in the name of the indicator,
and it's for day traders who want to
capitalize on short-term moves. Um swing
traders looking for to pinpoint entries
with stronger risk management. Maybe
you're trading on five minute, 15-inut
chart. and those uh traders that are
frustrated by lagging indicators, want
to upgrade their market analysis. And
again, Delta Scalper is meant for
short-term traders. It's not intended
for long-term buy and hold investors,
right? People say, "I'm going to buy um
you know, E- Minis today and hold it for
five months." You know, Delta Scalper is
not going to do you any good. You It's
not That's not the point of it. So, how
to get started with Delta Scalper? Well,
you need Ninja Trader 8 and it's going
to run on any bar or candle or orderflow
footprint chart. Now, I did say Reno,
but it not the native Ninja Trader Reno.
It's really um you need to use tick
replay. So, there are Reno charts out
there that do use tick replay. So, you
can use those indicators um like Uni
Reno from the indicator store, I
believe. Um, I know some traders had
mentioned to me that that's what they're
using. And again, it's basically
plug-and-play installation. No complex
adjustment or curve fitting required. It
integrates with your existing trading
methods or plan. And it's available at a
special price for a limited time.
All right. So, let's actually do this
here. I'll just pull up a chart here and
we'll add. So, this is uh E- Minis. What
do we got here? This is just a simple
one minute chart. Okay. So, of course,
like I said, you know, you need to have
tick replay enabled. Okay. And it's
enabled here. So, I'll just hit cancel.
You know, just uh I'll just add so you
know what time you know when I'm doing
this, right? You see the date and range
is up here. I'm recording this right
now. Market's closed. It's about 4:30 in
the afternoon Chicago time, but it's on
the uh 22nd of um July. So, I'll just
add the indicator on here. And again,
it's really simple. So, you just find
Delta Scalper. Okay. So after you get
it, you install it onto Ninja Trader as
you would any other thirdparty
indicator. Drop in your license token
and you only got to do that one time.
The license token is linked to your
Ninja Trader machine ID. So if your
machine ID changes, you need to um reset
your license token. Okay,
these are the default settings. Okay, so
we'll just add it on here. So multiple
time frame analysis, that's the default.
The positive delta strength ones,
negative delta strength one. You got
momentum strength down here. You've got
PC movements um and a swing filter.
Okay, so let's hit apply
just really quick. Again, I'm just
pulling up a an E- mini chart just to to
show you with the default settings.
Okay, so again, you see it up here in
the corner. It says calculating.
Add that on there. And again, I don't
necessarily recommend you keep changing
your charts during the course of the
day. Yeah, I I use tabs, right, with a
lot of different charts. So when I find
a setting that I like, I save the
template. Then I simply um
you know have it there. I I just open a
new tab with a new chart. So you see
here, this is just the default settings
for today. Um let's just go through, you
know, a couple of the settings really
quick. All right, the new one PC
movement default is set to five. I'll
put that on there really quick. And
you're going to see it's going to clean
up I say clean up the chart, but it's
going to should have fewer trades
because now it's looking for movements
in volume, right? PC is the price level
with the most volume. So, you know, now
I have just this nice short here and
this nice long here. And you know, this
is on cash close. I'm not too concerned
with it. But as before, I had uh a bunch
more. I had some buy signals, sell
signals. That's the PC movement. Um I do
have I am using the momentum strength.
Okay, so let me just go into this really
quick. Right, here's the period type. So
say this is you know I want to use say
I'm using a one minute chart but I want
faster signals. Right, I could actually
I talked about going up using a higher
time frame. You could actually go down.
You could use a shorter time frame 30
second chart. Okay, so a 30 second chart
with just the default settings. Let me
just show you that really quick,
right? Because you know when people
think of other time frames, they always
think of higher time frame. They don't
think of shorter time frame. People say,
"Why don't you just trade a 30 second
chart?" Well, I like the movement of a
of a one minute chart, but I'm willing
to take actually intraar signals.
Okay, so you see here people will say,
"Well, that's a lot of signals. Um, you
know, okay, how can we clean it up?"
Well, there's a couple ways. I do have
already the momentum filter on. I could
enter enable PLC movement. Maybe I don't
need to keep it so strong. I could uh
lower it down to say one or two. Okay,
just click apply
and just wait for it to come up. But
once you find like the settings that you
like, again, I recommend saving that
chart, saving those settings, save the
template. To save a template, it's easy.
All you got to do is you just go um
Whoops. Here you just go under
templates, right? and you just hit save
as. Okay. So now here is it's giving you
a lot fewer signals. Um again I'm just
pulling up charts. Let's pull up uh Euro
FX today.
Okay.
Right. Let's go back to this morning
here. Okay. So there's a nice move up. I
mean look at that move here. This and
again this is just using that same
setting that I had set with
the E- Minis, right? the 30 second
setting on a one minute chart. Momentum
strength set to three. PLC movement set
to um one, right?
I mean this is beautiful move basically
from 11745
all the way up I say 118 but at least up
to 90s in here. Okay. Um
I don't know gold. What gold do today?
Uh gold futures here.
All right. Again this is just the same
settings.
Right. Well, gold also had a nice move
like the Euro currency, right? But
someone caught this move up, this move
down, this move up, right? These small
moves down, small move up, sideways here
going into the close. What about crude?
Crude oil CL.
Okay.
Okay. So, there's a move up, move down,
move back up. That's around the close
4:00. But what about earlier? It's a
little bit choppy, but caught this nice
move up here, right? A little, you know,
caught this sharp move down as soon as
it happened. I mean, this is a 25cent
move down. Another 25cent move up. It
stopped out there. A little move here.
This move up, this move down.
All right. But again, you know, you can
adjust how you, you know, if there's,
you could adjust these settings. um
positive delta strength, negative delta
strength. You could go up a little bit
higher. I like to use one, two,
stronger. You know, the stronger you go
with the delta strength settings, uh
honestly, the fewer signals you will
get,
right? You see here, I was take a look
at say British
British pound. You know, I like futures
contract. Uh I like comm uh currency
contracts. These are all futures. Um,
you know, very strong signal because
it's set to two, but let's just go back
to set it to one. But again, these are
all the same setting.
All right. Even though I did change the
strength, but let's just back it off to
um one. All right. See here, it's nice
move there.
Okay.
Nice move up here. That's European
hours.
know platinum trader always ask me
what's platinum do how how does this
indicator work on platinum let's take a
look
now you know platinum is not one that's
on my normal radar but you know tra I do
get a lot of questions about you know
market like platinum so here's given
this group all these buys as a sell
didn't work out but there's a nice short
here nice short here nice long here a
nice short right here
and And this is all just today, July
22nd, as I'm recording this video. Okay?
And these are just, you know, different
markets. I I don't know how it looks on
wheats. I'm just thinking of markets
that are coming to the top of my mind
here.
I mean, look at that in the wheats,
right? Doom straight up and then back
down. Okay.
So, remember in trading there are no
magic bullets. just it's just about
finding a real edge. The Delta Scalper
isn't the holy grail. As with any
trading method, losses happen. Your
responsibility, though, is to use
prudent risk and stop management. Always
follow your plan. The goal is to filter
out weak trades, letting you keep losses
small and maximize the runs on high
quality trades. Delta Scalper provides
real market edge by interpreting live
order flow. No footprint chart is
necessary because remember I showed you
on um candlestick charts, right? the
Delta Scalper signals that are
generated. Delta Scalper is an advanced
tool and add it to your trading toolbox
for better consistency in edge. And
remember, Delta Scalper is not a
footprint chart, but it analyzes the
same information that is plotted on a
footprint chart. So, you don't have to
do that yourself. Okay? And you know,
the whole that that was the point of
programming Delta Scalper because I
remember years ago I was talking to my
programmer. I'm like, you know, this is
what I'm looking at in the order flow.
Can we just create a simple indicator
that reads the information from the
order flow and plots it on a simple bar
chart? And he said, I got you. Hold my
beer. I got you. And he he did it. He
came up with the Delta Scalper. Right.
So, to get started with Delta Scalper,
click on the link below and I'll see you
guys on the inside.